bonsoir nous sommes le 13 février
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 sur tv fil 78 en direct entre 18h et
19h ce soir je reçois tout d'abord josé
cache un bon soir vous êtes le directeur
de l'école paul fort à montigny le
bretonneux vous êtes venus ce soir nous
expliquer pourquoi les enseignants ne
veulent pas de cette réforme peillon de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires ils
étaient entre 30 et 60% dans le primaire
en grève à défiler hier comme vous et
vous nous expliquerez donc pourquoi dans
quelques instants pour l'instant voici
déjà les titres les sujets qui seront
développés au cours de cette édition
alors que l'automobile vite un climat
morose des constructeurs étrangers
tirent leur épingle du jeu c'est le cas
de mercedes à montigny ce mercredi lors
de la pose de la première pierre du
futur siège social à le directeur du
groupe france a annoncé une augmentation
de 9% de ses ventes pour la première
fois une opération de dépistage du sida
a été organisée au sein de l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin animé par
l'association icare et hf prévention
elle a concerné près de 90 étudiants
le 4l trophy s'élance ce jeudi depuis
poitiers derniers préparatifs pour les
équipes saint-quentinoise et notamment
pour un tandem d'elancourt et de trappes
il s'apprête à parcourir six mille
kilomètres à travers la france l'espagne
et le maroc
et puis en route pour le carnaval de
printemps à la merise de trappes des
ateliers ont été organisés pour se
mettre dans l'ambiance vous verrez les
images tout à l'heure puisque dans moins
d'une demi-heure nous ouvrirons une page
culture avec aurélia de bissy bonsoir
aurélien mais nous recevrons à cette
occasion trois invités tout à fait donc
trois invités pour parler de poésie mais
également des petites tracasseries voir
absurdités du quotidien
ce sera tout à l'heure la page culture
dans une demi heure pour le moment
éducation et nous revenons sur la
contestation d'hier
plus d'un instituteur sur trois en grève
hier mardi pour réclamer le report à
2014 de la réforme des rythmes scolaires
annoncé le ministère de l'éducation le
snuipp-fsu principal syndicat dans le
primaire a annoncé pour sa part près de
60% de grévistes josé cassandre bonsoir
vous n'êtes pas syndiqués je le dois à 6
tout de suite mais vous étiez en grève
exactement expliqué nous avons beaucoup
de mes collègues expliquer les raisons
de votre colère justement alors écoutez
on a plusieurs raisons
je dirais que la raison principale c'est
simplement le fait que pour tout vous
dire depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années je suis enseignant et des
réformes
on en a vu passer et des élèves on en a
vu également passé et qu'en l'espace
d'une vingtaine d'années les élèves ont
bien changé la société a bien changé et
que loin de nous l'idée de demander
l'abrogation d'une telle réforme
on a tous bien conscience dans le corps
enseignant qu'une réforme s'avère
indispensable
néanmoins et encore une fois malgré le
nombre incalculable de réformes qui
appuient avoir ces dernières années on a
le sentiment profond de ne pas avoir été
concerté comme on aurait dû l'être
on a vu quelques images pendant que vous
nous expliquer les raisons de vos
inquiétudes et des images qui ont été
tournées aussi bien dans vos locaux mais
également à trappes où 30 des 36 écoles
de la commune n'était pas ouverte une
centaine 150 écoles fermées sur les
mille que compte le département c'est ce
qu'annonce un et le snuipp-fsu la
mobilisation d'hier qui portaient donc
sur la réforme des rythmes scolaires et
certains syndicats comme cgt ou force
ouvrière mobiliser autre souci autour de
l'abandon plus globale de la réforme de
l'amélioration aussi des conditions de
travail et des salaires également est ce
que vous partagez aussi ses orientations
là et ces points de contestation
non c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles je suis pas suis pas syndiqué
si vous voulez bon je vais pas porter
une critique sur les syndicats mais
néanmoins il faut je pense qu'il faut
pas faire l'amalgamme de tous tout en
même temps
demander une abrogation de la réforme
non parce que cela sous-entendrait
évidemment qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas
d'accord sur le fait de repenser
l'école est loin de nous cette idée à
partir de là
voilà je veux dire on fait pas cavalier
seul parce que bien évidemment les
syndicats appellent à la grève
enfin la grande majorité d'entre eux
donc on les suit par rapport à ça mais
on a des inquiétudes qui sont très
ciblées et très particulière votre
inquiétude
un veau en particulier c'est la réforme
des rythmes scolaires c'est la réforme
des rythmes scolaires c'est c'est le
fait que au travers de ce décret on est
un certain nombre de points qui restent
quand même flou et qui font plus office
de bricolage qu'autre chose
et puis c'est surtout qu'on a des points
qui ne sont absolument pas aborder des
questions essentielles et notamment la
question des programmes par exemple
alors vincent peillon justement et qui
disait récemment à l'express que les
programmes seraient revues 1 cécile dit
le programme de 2002 à 2008 pardon
doivent être revues dans la transparence
la loi prévoit le retour du conseil
supérieur des programmes par exemple qui
avait été supprimée c'est ce qu'a
indiqué vincent peillon récemment dans
une interview je vous le disais à
l'express sas avait pas matière à vous
rassurer pour autant
non du tout parce que je crois quand
quand on met en place une telle réforme
il faut la mener jusqu'au bout
l'organisation de la journée des rythmes
scolaires doit être repensée dans son
ensemble là on nous annonce que on
travaillera le mercredi matin ou le
samedi matin à titre dérogatoire mais
quand on repense les rythmes scolaires
au plus profond que ça doit être
repensée il faut ne pas se contenter de
les repenser à la journée mais il faut
aussi repenser à la semaine il faut
repenser à l'année
les grandes vacances par exemple qui
doivent être reprises notre position
justement là-dessus parce que c'est
intéressant d'avoir un professeur non
syndiqués ses exploits sur cette
question disons qu'on a des coursières
les vacances d'été par exemple alors
écoutez on a des positions qui sont
peut-être divergentes les uns des autres
moi je vais pas parler au nom de tous
mes collègues les sénans mois ce qui
pourrait faire l'objet d'une
concertation intéressante pour ma part
il est bien évident que quand on veut
équilibrer un calendrier quand on veut
respecter une certaine chronobiologie
chez l'enfant etc
il est évident que ces deux mois de
vacances scolaires n'ont plus lieu
d'être
pour moi c'est une chose c'est trop long
quasi sûr voilà c'est trop long le fait
qu'on ait une coupure qui soit fait de
façon régulière tous les mois et demi
comme c'est le cas actuellement
ça paraît indispensable parce qu'on se
rend bien compte que les enfants sont
fatigués arriver à une certaine période
mais quand on a ces deux mois de
vacances qui ont une incidence terrible
à la fois sur la réadaptation si je puis
dire que les enfants doivent avoir en
début d'année et tout ce qui s'ensuit
deux mois c'est trop long mais ça c'est
un avis tout à fait cet avis tout à fait
personnel que vous avez émis ce soir l'a
bien compris ce qui vous inquiète aussi
dans cette réforme des rythmes scolaires
qui devrait arriver normalement pour
2013 c'était la règle à 2014 c'était
pour les dérogations d'ailleurs dans les
communes il faudra se prononcer d'ici la
fin du mois de mars pour ça est ce qui
vous inquiète aussi c'est peut-être
l'effet garderie que ça va entraîner
c'était l'une des craintes aussi des des
enseignants et même des parents d'élèves
c'est de voir le temps du midi peut être
un petit peu plus long aussi par exemple
qu'on reprenne les cours un petit peu
plus tard et puis on laisse les enfants
dans la cour de récréation le midi par
exemple le temps de midi un petit peu
plus long c'est aussi des unes des
propositions qui est fait mais comme
vous l'avez très bien dit on n'a pas
envie non plus que le temps périscolaire
se transforme en garderie et le problème
qui se pose avec ce décret c'est que
si vous voulez on n'a aucune garantie
d'une part d'un temps périscolaire
qu'ils soient gratuits
et puis qu'ils soient de qualité pour
tous ce que j'entends par là c'est que
on est quand même dans un pays où
l'école doit être gratuite
on doit avoir une école de qualité on
doit respecter une certaine forme
d'égalité donc il est bien évident que
dans des communes qui sont avec des
moyens financiers très compliqué et
c'est ça va être beaucoup plus difficile
pour eux de mettre ça en place que dans
les communes riches donc aussi quand
quand on met en place une telle réforme
il faut que ce soit une réforme qui soit
égal pour tous pour tous les enfants
quoi
et puis après effectivement se pose la
question de la façon dont se fera
l'encadrement périscolaire avec quel
personnel dans quels locaux
on a quand même trois mille six cents
élèves qui sont scolarisés sur la ville
de montigny le bretonneux
voilà donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
on n'a pas envie que ce temps là se
transforme en garderie ce qui serait
absolument catastrophique
pour la reprise après qu'on aurait des
enfants en cours quoi quand vous
entendez parler du corporatisme des
enseignants des enseignants qui se dore
figé immobile qui ne veulent pas avancé
non très honnêtement je pense que c'est
c'est une idée qui courent mais
justement je suis bien content d'être là
ce soir parce que si on les écoutait un
petit peu plus ses enseignants on se
rendrait compte que finalement l'image
qu'on peut en avoir n'est absolument pas
la bonne vous êtes enseignant depuis
depuis quand 23 ans et depuis tout ce
temps là toutes les réformes qui sont
passés pour vous pas une seule des
réformes n'a été bénéfique s'il faut
vraiment se remettre à plat aujourd'hui
non revoir les façons de consultation
des enseignants notamment non non non on
a eu des on a eu des bonnes réformes fin
dans leur globalité
tu jamais été très satisfaits de
l'intégralité des réformes enfin sur
certains points s'était dit ça a été des
bonnes réformes mais là on arrive à un
stade où véritablement il faut repenser
un certain nombre de choses et puis ça
doit même aller au delà de au delà de
l'école primaire je veux dire il ya tout
ce qui touche également après à la
formation etc
et c'est quoi la formation qui doit
évoluer normalement oui mais c'est quand
même que nous sommes derrière ce nom
devrait revenir aux fruits mais ça doit
se faire mais il aurait été bon que ça
se fasse en amont et qu'on nous présente
un décret avec un certain nombre de
choses qui soient bouclées et on aurait
ainsi le sentiment que c'est un c'est un
décret qui a été finalisée pensée
réfléchie et c est surtout un décret qui
soit fait dans l'intérêt de l'enfant et
on n'a pas le sentiment que sur tous les
points
ça joue dans l'intérêt de l'enfant et
puis surtout pour résumer pour
synthétiser ça va trop vite il faut
attendre 2014 ça va trop vite et vous
obtenez 2014 par exemple avec le
mouvement de contestation qui s'est
enclenchée ces dernières semaines vous
serez satisfait vous dirais ok ça nous
laisse une année supplémentaire pour
réfléchir mais écoutez là la
manifestation telle qu'elle s'est
présentée hier a bien montré une
inquiétude de
grandissante au sein du corps enseignant
le report à 2014 nous laisserait certain
temps de concertation beaucoup plus
conséquent et nous permettrait de mettre
en place avec les collectivités locales
un rythme scolaire qui corresponde
véritablement aux attentes mais il ya
d'autres points qui est aussi son obscur
et qui ont besoin d'être clarifiés d'ici
là donc si tout ça est fait pour la
rentrée 2014 il n'y a aucun problème
je rappelle que vous êtes enseignants de
primaire directeur d'école à montigny le
bretonneux merci de votre témoignage ce
soir sur le plateau je vous rappelle
aussi à l'information puisque c'est la
raison principale de cette mobilisation
ce décret publié fin en fin janvier qui
prévoit le retour à la semaine de quatre
jours et demi dès 2013 avec école le
mercredi matin
sauf à titre dérogatoire est les
communes qui ont jusqu'au 31 mars pour
se prononcer peuvent attendre 2014 et
opter pour le samedi matin
pour l'instant la contestation n'a pas
été entendu puisque le décret n'a pas
changé et c'est pour l'instant ce qui
est prévu nous verrons comment cela
évolue bien sûr dans les prochaines
semaines dans un instant vous allez
entendre le témoignage d'une année sous
x les roses du mensonge c'est le nom de
son ouvrage
isabelle jeanne andré pourquoi ce livre
pourquoi ce combat nous lui demanderons
juste après un détour par l'université
de versailles saint quentin pour la
première fois une opération de dépistage
du sida y était organisé animé par les
étudiants de l'association icare et hf
prévention les images
marie-france et retraités elle est
bénévole au sein d' hf prévention et
elle a participé à l'opération dépistage
du vih au sein de l'université de
versailles saint quentin avant le test
minutes les étudiants répondent à des
questions concernant notamment leurs
pratiques sexuelles
des pistes nous on n'est pas les parents
avec les parents peut-être ils vont pas
discuter de tout ça avec des personnes
comme nous ça nous dérange pas et puis
s'ils ont envie de parler bien bien sur
wii a aucun problème
après le questionnaire il est donc
possible de bénéficier d'un test gratuit
une minute pour savoir pour montrer aux
gens qu'il faut que tout le monde puisse
lui que tous puissent faire ce test très
important c'est très rapide on puis ça
fait pas mal
puis bon c'est une bonne un bon moyen
d'éviter d'aller faire des prises de
sang
c'est la première fois qu'à chef
prévention organisent une opération de
dépistage rapide à l'université en
partenariat avec l'association
d'étudiants icare et ce n'est pas anodin
on sent quand même un besoin des
étudiants de se faire dépister bas sur
leur lieu de vie étant donné que ils
n'ont pas toujours les moyens de se
déplacer vous prendre le train attrape
les rendez vous c'est que le jeudi soir
donc c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
problématique avec leur emploi du temps
c'est les étudiants qui sont très au
courant il ya des étudiants qui ont
proposé des pistes est ce qu'ils nous
disent ah bah non à ces faits gelée fait
ya deux mois il n'y a pas de problème et
puis on croise aussi des étudiants qui
nous disent ah non moi je me protège pas
je vois pas à quoi ça sert les étudiants
c'est le coeur de sites tout comme
effectivement les populations
homosexuelles ou les styles et les
populations donc précaire aux migrants
effectivement les jeunes font partie des
priorités en tout cas des nouvelles
priorités donc du gouvernement et on se
retrouve effectivement avec des jeunes
qui sont inquiets de leur statut
sérologique
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle de voir
qu'ils ont une prise de conscience sur
donc les risques sexuels
l'idée pour hf prévention c'est
d'intervenir plus régulièrement à
l'université à raison d'une fois tous
les deux mois
l'association est également hébergé au
sein de l'institut de promotion de la
santé à trappes en une journée de
présence à lui vs qu 85 jeunes se sont
fait dépister tous négatifs